ARRIVE.
CAULFIELD OVER THE BOARDS BUT
PLAYED AHEAD FOR BARCLEY GOODROW
D POINT STAYING OUT FOR THE
LIGHTNING.
BRAYDEN POINT WITH A MOVE TO THE
OUTSIDE AGAINST PETRY.
SWOOPS IT AROUND BEHIND THE NET.
BACK TO CERNAK.
HIS SHOT KNOCKED DOWN IN THE
SLOT.
BARCLEY GOODROW, TRYING TO COME
OUT OF THE CORNER.
OW ROMANOV AND COLEMAN.
ANDERSON TAKES IT AWAY FROM HIM.
CHI IT PAST RUTTA.
HE'S GOT CAULFIELD IN FRONT.
AND THE CENTERING PLAY.
CAULFIELD!
ANDERSON SCORES!
[Horn sounds]
JOSH ANDERSON!
EXTENDS THE SERIES!
CANADIENS STAY ALIVE!
AND THERE WILL BE GAME FIVE!
[Cheering and Applause]
>> Chris: FIRST GOAL OF THE
NIGHT FOR JOSH ANDERSON.
LAST GOAL OF THE NIGHT FOR JOSH
ANDERSON.
AND THE SERIES GOES BACK TO
TAMPA BAY!
>> Craig: THE PENALTY KILL DID
THEIR JOB.
AND NOW ANDERSON WHO HASN'T BEEN
PLAYING FOR A WHILE BECAUSE OF
IT.
WATCH THE SPACE,HE PLAY HE
MAKES IN THE DEFENSIVE ZONE.
LIFTS THE STICK O GOURDE.
USES HIS BEST SKILL.
BUT THE "D."
HE DOESN'T GO BY THE NET.
ON THE NET.
BEFORE RUTTA CAN.
CAULFIELD KEEPS IT ALIVE IN
FRONT.
THE SPEED OF ANDERSON MADE THIS
POSSIBLE BUT HIM STOPPING AND
GETTING BACK TO THE FRONT OF THE
NET MAKES THAT GOAL HAPPEN.
KEPT THE PLAY ALIVE.
RIGHT HERE WITH A LITTLE TIP
BACK OFF OF A STICK OF YANNI
GOURDE.
AND THEN DIVING BACK IS.
JOSH ANDERSON SENDS THIS BACK TO
TAMPA.
FOR GAME NUMBER FIVE.
>> Chris: 3:57 OF OVERTIME.
ABOUT A MINUTE AFTER THE DOUBLE
MINOR HAD BEEN KILLED.
SCORED IN OVERTIME WINNER
AGAINST VEGAS IN GAME THREE.
AND GAME FOUR WINNER HERE
TONIGHT!
>> Craig: YOU ARE THINKING
DEFENCE FIRST.
THAT'S HIS WHOLE MOTIVE BUT JUST
AN EXCELLENT READ.
THEN A LITTLE CHIP.
NOW IT IS A FOOTRACE.
AND THIS LAST EFFORT TO THROW
THAT PUCK OUT IN FRONT.
CREATES THE SECOND CHANCE AS
CAULFIELD GETS A PIECE OF IT.
THIS CROWD ANXIOUS MOMENTS WITH
A FOUR MINUTE PENALTY KILL.
CAREY PRICE.
THINK OF THOSE SAVES.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIS CALM ALL
THROUGHOUT THE PLAYOFFS.